yeah yeah you arranged though are you in
range I don't know let's should I find
out is that come forward a bit got bored
of it because you want to remember your
aim is to punch through the bag through
so I want to go like that yes I like
that
[Applause]
182
okay here we go okay with what do any to
182 to beat
[Applause]
was attending well you don't care and
then you do yeah come but just have a
staredown with zoom laughs first okay
[Applause]
it's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
five nine four to be here we go here we
go
[Applause]
Anthony Joshua aren't you know anyone Oh
No
[Applause]
I'm still going okay I tell you what was
yours eight eight P was three thousand
six and two wasn't what six seven two
six three two so if you don't beat that
long so tightly okay okay here we go
this technique adieu the world
[Applause]
we found this picture of an ox look at
this look at this now we needed the face
of it you've never seen a happier
creature on planet Earth look how happy
this holler is off with his new teddy
bear depressed I can give them to a
mammal I said that the command I picked
up my phone and I went will need a big
teddy bear now however the big the word
big is quite relative yeah they've gone
with a really enormous teddy bear
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but it's it's just there's something I
don't know something about it that makes
me want to kind of do
[Applause]
take it there think of Mike Keota
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good reaction to a fork well done this
one's a nice light one oh I see I could
do that
I do break a lot of these okay I mean I
do break a lot of them but the statue of
you was unveiled no I did not
Ryan in fact I didn't know that was
going up I learned the first day that
was up they said hey look what's up in
there and I went Wow well things we
thought oh how lovely we could wear you
know bring the statue here and showed
you I was like we hadn't quite
understood the scale of this I read what
it was it's like 25 feet long and so etc
10 so all I can offer you all right if
you're allowed to keep this I heard
about this but I've not seen it yes
Wow this
is just over his head Hey
excuse my excuse my budget really look
at that thing oh my golly hey Jeff you
can post it on Facebook fun is the
lowest form of humor true or false
let's see Wow
well I thought that would be I thought
it was made of its like papier-mache I
thought it would be concrete of some
kind take that home
I'm not sure we can give it to you I'll
be giving it up no no no somebody wants
it back I don't know what I'd do it I
didn't I I didn't realize it could be
decapitated but I then I think when they
told me it was sectional you know
imagine if this were like a voodoo doll
I would have felt something but you know
ok survive attack tube is a bit of
fruits you like it hurt no seriously
would you hurt me like will you break my
arm I'll go very slow I'm sick now I
think this is amusing idea
no seriously ok ok do you really promise
I swear pinky do you trust her you
should totally
[Applause]
so if you were gonna stab me would you
really hold a knife like that
no I feel I'm sorry oh wait I'm holding
it wrong
I'll disarm you the minute you start
holding it properly
so like that well no okay fine
sure no I was like oh this this is fine
so base no no wait a minute no how do
you like if you're gonna stab me there
you go perfect
let's do it again okay so I'm coming at
you yeah then I go like this I'm doing
it so much and so I don't hurt you
[Applause]
didn't even bruise the banana saying
that he wants to do this okay you sure
yeah okay I know there's something I
have to say that this is legally don't
try this at home okay perfect okay here
we go
okay in your own time okay here we go
haven't done one for a while I'm sorry
I'm probably sorry that's not comforting
I'm not going to say that wasn't very
professional I'm scared
my hands are shaking but you don't hear
that
[Applause]
okay
does it hurt a little funny don't we
make your finest work
you do seem happy in your work good I
like doing it
[Applause]
good neaten it up like one we're off
like backstage
[Applause]
[Music]
you